the 1930s the scientist Arthur C gisa
started with a group of blepharisma that
had grown up on bacteria the blepharisma
he was working with weren't large enough
to eat each other yet but they could eat
a ciliate called tetrahymena that was
smaller than them but larger than
bacteria after eating the tetrahymena
the blepharisma grew then starved of
their tetrahymena diets the giant
blepharisma were set upon a batch of
blepharisma that were small enough to
stuff in their microbial gullet the
smaller blepharisma who did not stand a
chance within minutes most of the giant
blepharisma gisa observed had eaten at
least one blepharisma eight hours later
he found one giant had eaten 12.